yo les Narvalo envoyez le matos
je vous adopte Bernie la brute fait
taffer une bande de tortue quoi non on
travaille pas pour Bernie on est là
parce qu'on cherche pas à croire qu'il
existe d'autres mutants comme nous non
j'avoue c'est waouh une vraie dinguerie
attendez laissez-moi deviner il y a 15
ans de ça en gros on a versé une
substance bizarre dans les égouts et
vous avez trempé dedans c'est ça on
préfère parler de fluide mais c'est pas
grave ça sonne mieux c'est plus simple
le fluide ça claque le fluide bonbon
écoutez les gars je suis né du même
fluide que vous ok c'est mon daron
Baxter Stockman c'est Lui qui a créé le
fluide balancé dans les égouts mes
petits loups donc techniquement on est
cousins ouais
on est de la maison j'ai toujours voulu
avoir un cousin bah ça tombe bien parce
qu'on est un paquet